in this video we shall showcase to you
all the 11 space kaiju that have been
seen in the godzilla franchise
godzilla himself is an underwater kaiju
for most of his incarnations that is
there are also ancient kaijus and flying
ones
but all of the most dangerous animals
utilize are the space
kaiju the things that they are from
space
and their origin stories and their
intentions towards planetary domination
has always been an easy way to explain
and did you know that among these
monsters on the list
there is one that even dwarfs godzilla
earth in size and we shall dive more
into that in
another video so among these creatures
most of them are aliens while some of
them are mutated
godzilla cells and godzilla alien
hybrids
so if you want to find out then check
this video out but wait
check this out ever dreamt of battling
dark fantasy creatures and monsters
great shadow legends is a game and a
universe in itself that fits in your
pocket with amazing graphics and smooth
gameplay
you can surf it with 500 champions that
you can choose from with their own skill
sets and all the time battling enemies
and facing all sorts of challenges
while also upgrading your gear skills
and levels there are also millions of
artifacts
you can find they just released the
artifact forge if you wanna know
so you can save time and craft artifacts
directly
as well as a new advanced quest system
which includes rewards what's life
without rewards right
anyway there are also amazing new
champions that are going to be released
as well as a doom tower
which sounds like a mission to slay
count dracula himself
if you're quick enough you can use my
link in the description and this will
get you an exclusive welcome pack that
contains 10 mystery shots 1 energy
refill 100k silver and a free champion
slasher
so escape this 2020 crisis world and
download this game
asap number one space godzilla
also known as astro godzilla and crystal
godzilla this giant monster stands
around
120 meters tall and 250 meters long
while in his crystal form
and weighs 80 000 tons and 720 000 tons
in his crystal flying form
it is confirmed that he is indeed a
clone of godzilla originating from outer
space
but the exact details behind his
creation have varied but he is from
space
space godzilla is one of the most
intelligent of godzilla's foes in the
series
showing planned combat strategy he looks
very similar to godzilla in many ways
with a navy blue skin and also reddish
in some parts
he has two massive white crystals that
erupt from his shoulders and also his
dorsal blades
and his tail is much longer ending in
several crystal spikes
number two auger the second one in this
list is yet another kaiju that has some
godzilla in it
and this monster is orga he is the
result of the millennium
aliens absorbing godzilla's organizer g1
cells into their collective form
aurga is a hulking monstrosity
possessing godzilla's strength and
enhanced regenerative abilities
after being transformed into a deformed
creature rather than a perfect clone of
godzilla
orga fought and attempted to subdue
godzilla so he could fully engulf him
and completely absorb his
characteristics orga then proved to be a
challenging opponent for godzilla due to
his
potent healing factor immense strength
and telephotic abilities
appearing in godzilla 2 000 millennium
he has 60 meters tall and 45 000 tons
number three dragon one of the most
famous of the
space aliens in the godzilla franchise
he has a cybernetically enhanced kaiju
of the nebulae aliens
this kaijus dragon and he is one of the
recurring villains of godzilla alongside
mecha godzilla and ghidorah
this one is truly a strange monster
sporting a circular saw weapon located
in his frontal abdominal region
large steel hooks for hands with smaller
ones for toes
spikes running down his tail three large
fin-like spines on his back and a red
cybernetic visor
for an eye dragon is sometimes
considered godzilla's
most brutal and violent opponent he is
capable of flying at up to mark 3 in the
earth's atmosphere but in space he is
capable of flying
millions of times faster than light by
encasing himself in a diamond
number 4 ghidorah next we have the
ultimate nemesis of godzilla
one who has faced the g-man and quite a
number of battles
and is always depicted as being much
bigger than godzilla himself
he has for the most part always been an
extraterrestrial entity
that comes down to earth to destroy or
terraform it for his liking
however he has also been a guardian
monster of japan
anyway ghidorah is an evil space monster
responsible for wiping out all life on
many planets across the universe
earth is just one of his targets but he
is usually opposed by godzilla
as well as other monsters like mothra
and rodan he is a three-headed dragon
with three long necks two large wings
and two tails with spiny club ends
his last appearance was in kotm as
monster zero
number five hidora one of the strangest
opponents that godzilla has ever had the
pleasure to encounter
and destroy hidaro was an alien
pollution kaiju
and was also known as the smog monster
hidora was an alien life form from the
dark gas galaxy
hedorah was an alien life form from the
dark gas nebula
in the orion constellation that landed
on earth traveling under comet
for at least 243 light years in godzilla
final wars
hidora was one of the many monsters
under the control of the zillions
but his origin and how he came under the
zillions is never explained
he has four forms and the final one
resembles well
resembles nothing normal at all it looks
like melting pieces of scrap metal one
on top of another
he isn't actually evil but hedorah seems
to be primarily driven by instinct and
the will to survive
number six death ghidorah yes it was not
clubbed alongside ghidorah because
of its many differences between them and
that it was classified as a relative
of ghidorah rather than a version of it
that's ghidorah is an alien creature and
gains power from destroying and feeding
off the live energies
of the planets it ravages it arrived in
the solar system 65 million years ago
and cleansed mars of life before moving
on to earth
which at the time was inhabited by the
alias and mothra the resultant battle
obliterated the earliest civilization
but des ghidora was defeated and locked
away in a mystical sealed chamber
so no one could ever release him at 50
meters and 75
000 tons he is one big alien kaiju that
mothra defeated
and not godzilla number seven monster x
while initially being dubbed as monster
x he was later called as kaiser ghidorah
following his transformation from the
bipedal
to the full-legged monster which looked
like des ghidora in structural
appearance
in the alien monster x form he is a
bipedal creature with an
exoskeleton-like armored skin
he possesses two small half skulls on
his shoulders and a long black forked
tail
he also had red eyes a skeletal face and
long spikes on the top of his head
in the kaiser ghidorah form he
incorporates elements of both king
ghidorah and death ghidorah in
appearance
like that's ghidorah kaiser ghidorah is
quadripedal and like king ghidorah he
has a golden skin but
with much smaller wings he is the third
biggest ghidorah at 140 meters and a
hundred thousand tons
he was summoned by the zillions from an
asteroid called gorath
number eight dogora so up next we have a
very weird looking creature called
degora
and it is defined as a mutant space cell
kaiju that appeared first in the 1964
film of the same name
it was later seen in godzilla island
series and godzilla plan of the monsters
briefly
de gora is a space cell that lived in
the earth's upper atmosphere
the cell was exposed to a huge cloud of
radiation located in the atmosphere over
japan
causing it to mutate rapidly the cell
then began to require large amounts of
carbon to sustain itself and so it
descended to earth to feed on carbon
sources like diamonds
and coal although it initially resembles
a bluish amoeba-like blob
and a green vapor it later evolved into
a jellyfish-like creature with
squid-like tentacles
number nine vegeta this creature only
appeared in the comics published by idw
and was a very massive triloport alien
kaiju
and these triloports are aliens that
have a similar design choice to the
xenomorph
from the alien movies majita is very
similar in appearance to the beta
triloport brethren
but is considerably more massive and
completely dwarves godzilla and his
allies
majita possesses many segments on its
head as well as dozens of circular
glowing patches of on the sides of its
necks
mochita's arms are very long and are
chipped with sharp spikes
where magita and the other teleport
buddies are from
is unknown but one fact is that she is
from outer space
and she is way bigger than godzilla and
might even be the biggest kaiju ever
number 10 megalon although megalon was a
gigantic insectoid being
that lives deep underground in the
subterranean kingdom of cetopia
and was seen as the cetopian's god in
the godzilla island series however he
was a minion
of the zillion aliens and was brought to
earth to battle against the other
monsters
its design is that of an underground
creature megalon is noticeably colorful
combining silver and grey tasks with
claws with an orange and black carapace
and wings
megalon's four limbs terminate with two
sharp drill-like appendages
which are never seen to be individually
prehensile at least in godzilla vs
megalon
always moving into tune with the
monster's arms
number 11 mecha godzilla although there
are many versions of the metal g-man the
original mecha godzilla was not a
creation of humanity
but of an alien species and thus he was
brought to earth from outer space
the first version of the character was
introduced in the 1974 film godzilla vs
maker godzilla
where it was a creation of the evil
black hole planet 3 aliens
designed to destroy godzilla and conquer
the earth the first incarnation was a
giant robot model after godzilla with a
silver colored body
orange and yellow eyes and a weapon pot
on its torso
it was first seen disguised as godzilla
and even defeated anguirus in battle
until it was intercepted by godzilla in
tokyo and forced to shed its skin
to reveal a metallic alien robot kaiju
and so with that we come to the end of
the list of the 11 outer space kaiju
that have appeared in a godzilla
franchise subscribe and hit that
notification bell for more of these
videos in the future